okay let us talk about Ted Bundy do you
know anything about Ted Bundy before we
begin I don't really know much about Ted
he was born in Vermont in 1946. so he
had a bit of a tumultuous upbringing Ted
was brought up by his grandma
right thinking that his grandma was his
actual mum and his actual mum he thought
he was his sister great so we're
starting off at a terrible place and he
goes to college he goes to he finishes
high school goes to college and he meets
a woman
this woman
her name was Diane Edwards he loves
Diane Diane is his number one boo like
he loves love First Love he's full of
then he's deep and I date for a while
and you know
they're living it up but at one point
Diane doesn't think that Ted is
ambitious enough for her so she breaks
up with him so she breaks up he's not
ambitious enough she was like a certain
lifestyle he's not cutting the mustard
he does not take this well
to put this lightly he is devastated he
is unhappy he is not okay with the whole
breakup yeah uh but that's okay you know
you know things happen you know he
breaks up whatever so he moves on and he
meets another woman great he meets one
other woman called Elizabeth
so she was a single mother and had a
child and they met at a bar and he
supposedly fell in love with her at
first sight okay
okay and he was very willing to
look after her and look after her child
I think she was very wary of course in
that time
there was like a huge stigma around uh
single mothers and where the fathers
were so he finishes college degree as a
Psychology major okay yeah interesting
point and he worked for the Republican
party at one point the local Republican
party
um and was accepted into law school so
he starts doing quite well for himself
so he's in California and guess who he
bumps into who is he bump into he bumps
into his old flame his old lover who
broke his heart Diane they bump into
each other and she goes my God
he's so put together he's so mature and
he's so ambitious so ambitious so
ambitious I'm falling in love with him
Oliver again
so they start dating again and she's
obsessed with him
and suddenly
he just cut off all contacts with her
so he's in California just stops talking
to her stops replying to her ghosts
there so at one point I think it's maybe
a year later she finally gets back
through to him and she goes what
happened a year oh year passes this is
kind of you know a year past and she was
what happened and apparently the words
that he then spoke to her chilled her to
her core
he went Diane I have no idea what you
mean and then hung up he'd just been
Petty she'd broken up with him he moves
on gets back together with her only to
break up with her and do what she did to
him back to her I think that's beyond
Petty bearing in mind at this point he
is still dating Elizabeth oh we then
move on to the first attack if you will
the first kind of incident where he is
assaulting women 4th of January 1974.
this is interesting so this is his first
attack but she survives so he sneaks
into uh a house where there is a young
woman sleeping and he bludgeons her with
a metal rod that has been taken from her
bed frame he then uh a month later
commits his first kill essentially he
breaks into a basement apartment
and finds Linda and Healy so that is the
name of his first ever victim who dies
from the attacks
so he beats her unconscious and she's in
a nightgown which is completely covered
in blood completely covered in blood so
he takes her out of that and puts her in
other clothes from her wardrobe and puts
that in her wardrobe right so it looks
like you know nothing's really happened
which I think investigators later
thought when they saw it or she just
like had a nosebleed because it was hung
up so they thought oh that's a bit crazy
is that going to be the first sign of
just terrible police work
he then starts taking and assaulting and
killing a lot of students a lot of
female students from the University of
Washington and they all start
disappearing from their dormitories
which I so I don't know much but I feel
like didn't they all look really similar
isn't that a thing yeah so what's really
interesting about how they looked is
they all had they were all very pretty
they had long dark hair parted down the
middle most of them uh and you know who
else had long dark hair parted down the
middle I think I can guess his uh
ex-girlfriend who broke his heart Diane
oh of course it was Diane so the only
clue that they have at this point is
that someone had seen one of the women
or had seen a man with a Volkswagen
Beetle or bug uh like a tan colored bug
and a guy carrying a load of books
wearing a sling asking for help to carry
the books to his car
so he was
essentially preying on people's kindness
yeah in June uh he
knocks another student unconscious drags
her away and murders her and her name is
georgeanne Hawkins now he handcuffed her
and I think he strangled her
and then spent the entire night with her
body so you can only imagine what was
going on in those nights so next morning
he did realize that he had I think left
something behind I know about this right
yeah so he left something behind and
I think we can assume that Ted Bundy was
a very egotistical man who thought a lot
of himself and and
I don't know if narcissistic is
specifically the right word but elements
of that because he went back to that
scene of the crime he went back to where
she was whilst there were police
officers there whilst there were
Detectives
at the scene of the crime investigating
he went back figured a way to sneak past
them and located her earrings and one of
her shoes and took them without being
spotted why did he take oh did he take
them because he thought that like some
of his DNA was going to be on them or
something I don't know but I do know
that he did have rituals rituals when he
killed women he would take Polaroids of
their bodies he would take certain
um pieces of clothing so there were a
lot of pantyhose that we would take
clothing from women that at one point I
think Elizabeth his girlfriend with the
kid found and became very suspicious but
he would take like little mementos of
each of the women so I think I wonder
whether that's what that was like a
trophy thing he would also I think
sometimes shampoo the hair of the girls
that he'd killed post killing them and
put makeup on them to make them look a
little bit more presentable oh my God I
know yeah really quite weird so he
essentially becomes a little bit more
bold in the way in which he's taking
these women he's getting out of the way
I can feel it so this is essentially
where he makes a big mistake so he goes
to Lake samamish and it's really crowded
and really busy and it's in Broad
Daylights and I can't remember how many
people were there there are a lot a lot
of people there like tens of thousands
of people there
um and he
does the sling he gets his arm in a
sling and he goes around asking people
whether they would help him put a
sailboat into the back of his van
okay and he can't do it because he's in
this link but two women say yes
now
their remains were found later these two
women so he abducted them and killed
them and did what noted their bodies but
the issue is and this is the mistake he
made he
there were Witnesses
so there were people who heard him
introducing himself to these girls
because his name with his real name at
that point there were so many
eyewitnesses the police were able to
come up with a sketch a little okay
because hey the first bit of evidence
the first bit of evidence as to what
this guy looked like so they knew his
name was Ted and they knew that
looked like that and guess who
recognizes the
SE
um is it uh his girlfriend which one the
one with the kids yes yes so Elizabeth
Club for Liz she calls me she goes
listen my boyfriend a bit weird but he
looks like the drawing and he's called
Ted and he drives that car
so I just thought I'd like give you that
information it's called Ted Bundy so
they have this massive database of
people and at this point Ted is like a
really clean-cut law student so it's
kind of unlikely that right they they're
going to be like oh well it's this guy
but they put his name down and they just
have it on file on the database just in
case
um anyway so at this point Ted still
hasn't been caught and he's living his
free life and he's accepted into a
university in Utah so he's he's in he
moves to Salt Lake City because he's at
the University there and he leaves
Elizabeth with her kid in Seattle so
interestingly the deaths in Seattle stop
as soon as he arrives he starts
killing people right there was a
hitchhiker that he strangled a 16 year
old who has never been found and then he
abducted uh the police chief's daughter
and killed her and her body is found
kind of nine days later uh completely
naked in the mountains and it's said
that she may have been alive up to seven
days after her disappearance right so
quite traumatizing I would argue so I
missed out a mistake he makes three big
mistakes okay so the first one was
abducting in pure daylight and using his
real name this is his second mistake so
he now is another Survivor so he poses a
police officer and approaches Carol de
Ranch and he approaches her and says I'm
a police officer someone's tried to
break into your car come check it out
with me and she goes that's a bit weird
it's like why is you know this this
feels bizarre why are you in normal
clothes like what's going on and she
goes well I'm not getting in a car like
with you where's your badge so he shows
her the badge so she's questioned him
and she's gone and he's gone here's my
badge and she goes okay I'm embarrassed
sorry follows him to the car uh gets in
the car
they're driving around and she goes a
bit weird how his police cars are
Volkswagen like that's a bit weird
anyway he takes a wrong turn she
questions it he suddenly launches over
puts handcuffs on her and says something
along the lines of I'm going to blow
your head off so that's what she can
remember so that's important anyway at
one point there's a bit of a scuffle and
she manages to escape so she escapes and
she runs away and she jumps into a car
hysterical crying and just says just a
car that was approaching just goes drive
me to the police station so she drives
the police station
and um
and reports what has happened at this
point there's been disappearances in
Salt Lake and Elizabeth with the kid
yeah his girlfriend called up the piece
she's like listen something is going on
like there's been disappearances in Salt
Lake I'm calling you again because my
boyfriend has now moved there and
there's disappearances like something
needs to happen he then gets arrested
okay but he gets arrested for driving
too fast so a routine traffic incident
he's just speeding unrelated unrelated
and he gets pulled up so take him into
the police station and they see in his
car that he's got that he's got
handcuffs an ice pick
crowbar rope and also he had a ski mask
as items for serial killers go yeah I
would say hi up there ski masks
definitely cherry on the cake they
arrest him and while the guys are asking
him he's like there's some weird things
in his car they flag it up they search
his house they flew out Elizabeth to be
interviewed uh and at that point she was
quizzed on the things that she'd found
in her home we're getting somewhere
there is a lot of evidence now against
Ted but not enough to convict him not
enough but but they're very suspicious
so what they do Carol de Ranch the girl
that got away from him in the car when
he posed to be a police officer yes they
call in a selection of people for a
lineup and they bring Carolyn for and
this is for aggravated kidnapping they
bring Carol in and they go literally
which one is it like who did it you know
the classic lineups yeah and so they all
stand forward and they go I'm gonna blow
your head off and they all use that line
because that's what he said to her
anyway so he tried to get out away from
it so he like switched his parting he
shaved his mustache so he like wouldn't
be recognizable didn't work Carol goes
that's him that's the guy that tried to
kidnap me and picks him out of the crowd
so nethergood
he is then uh found guilty and he is
charged with kidnapping and assault
so he's sentenced to up to 15 years in
prison when he's in prison they keep
investigating him and then later that
year he's charged with one of the
murders of the girl like one of them I'm
not sure which girl it was but he's
charged with a murder okay
so okay for that he then decides to
represent himself in court big ego loves
himself he's like I'm a law student I
know all of this information letting his
ego just blind him this is where it gets
a bit interesting so because he was
choosing to represent himself he was
able to convince the judge that he
should be allowed to use like the law
library and use all of these resources
available to lawyers to help his own
case which makes sense so while he was
doing that someone wasn't looking so
he's in there he's not got any Shackles
on he's able to use all the books
and there's an open window second floor
open window and he jumps out
injures his foot and he runs away
sorry this is a cartoon
that's how he escaped from prison oh
yeah just dropped out the window I know
he was on the run for almost a week but
he was cold and tired and sleep deprived
and Delirious and in pain and ultimately
ended up back in the back in the
district picked up by police and put
back in a prison cell and he's in jail
he's planning his second Escape they've
locked all the windows they've locked
all the windows they feel great about it
exactly and he's planning his second
Escape so he acquired like a floor plan
of everything he got a hacksaw and when
the prisoners showered I'm sorry I need
to pause yeah he got a hacksaw okay so
he's in jail so valid valid query when
he was doing odd jobs around the jail he
would pick up things here and there pop
it in a sock yeah but he would require
lots of things and when uh all the
prisoners were showering because there
was a lot of noise going on around he
would use that time to saw a little hole
in the ceiling
so it is a cartoon thank you for
clarifying that so it was at Christmas
time he escaped he gets out through the
hole and this is like the kind of this
is his biggest spree his biggest Killing
Spree at this point and also how he ends
up getting caught as well so he escapes
and then and then he's out for how long
they don't clock that he's gone until 70
has a 17-hour head start so he ended up
in Florida
rough choice because big on the death
penalty there but ended up in Florida
and it was so just went on a matted
Killing Spree so the biggest one he did
he went to this Kai Omega house which
was a sorority house in Florida at the
University of Florida I believe and he
entered the house at 2AM and attacked
the students as they slept for this
attack he kills two women and injured
two one I think he sexually assaulted so
badly her spleen ruptured it was just
Dreadful and he killed two others so
there were four injured women and it was
just the worst yeah then he did his
final murder the victim was 12. oh so
she was leaving her school and he
abducted and killed her and her remains
were found later mummified at pig farm
and that one her name was Kimberly Leach
and yeah that was a bit of a kicker
because I think she was so young and
actually he refused to talk about her
death when he was being questioned when
he confessed he refused to talk about
her because she was so young so he's
driving away he's killed his 12 year old
girl he's killed all these people he's
on the run from the police and he's in a
car he's in a stolen car and the police
flag it up he is obviously like [ __ ]
because he's on the run from police the
last thing he wants to be done is pulled
over for anyway so they shouldn't have
stolen the car anyway sorry go on a bit
of a scuffle with the police officer and
they arrest him and take him in right so
at this point uh they have a trial right
so that's when his trial starts because
at this point the police are like okay
you are very clearly very guilty so the
jury found him guilty they found him
guilty for two murders three counts of
attempted murder and two counts of
burglary
and do we know which specific accounts
they are or are they just it's one of
the many one of the many because he
didn't confess to any of them right
until the day before he died and oh okay
cool so he was for those murders
sentenced to death six months later he
was then charged with Kimberly Leach the
12 year old's murder as well I believe
it was nine years after he was sentenced
to death that the execution date was set
so it was in like nine years he spent
trying to appeal this and of course he
did he was in that he was constantly
trying to appeal everything to buy
himself more time constantly kind of buy
himself more time so he could get out of
it it was the day before he was set to
be executed he finally confessed up
until that day nine years he was
vehemently just like I did not do it
until the day before he was like [ __ ] it
yeah this is what I did it's over but he
only confessed to 30. and there were
more than 30 only 20 of those victims
were ever identified and he didn't want
to talk about a couple of them he was
finally executed at 7 16 on January the
24th 1989. one thing that I would love
to know is what he got for his death row
meal so Ted was given the stat
Florida's death row which was staked on
medium rare eggs over easy toast with
butter and jelly or Jam that's what we
call it milk coffee juice and hash
browns
foreign
[Music]
delicious tasty wow so this is what we
had oh but I wouldn't go for any of it
because Ted actually declined a meal in
the first place so this is just the
standard meal they give every prisoner
who doesn't ask for anything and then
when they gave him the dish he ate none
of it so he actually died on an empty
stomach
I remember the first week my Charter
said can you go up to the toilets there
and just check on that patient and I
went up and the next minute he had me by
the neck and he was trying to strangle
me and it was fight or flight